For most travelers, visiting Japan is like visiting another planet.
Tokyo's futuristic skyscrapers extend to every point on the horizon.
Its colossal billboards pulse and shimmer, lighting up whole city blocks.
Fantastic too, are the sleek bullet trains...
...that race across pastoral landscapes at frightening speeds.
And Kyoto's demure kimono-clad women...
...strolling through the pine-shaded courtyards...
...of ancient zen temples appear like visions from a dream.
In all of its everyday expressions, Japan is enchanting, bewildering, and intimidating.
But if you're a food professional, or simply an enthusiast, you need to go there.
So, join us as we explore Japan from north to south.
We'll stop at Tokyo's enormous Tsukiji market,...
...known for its astonishing selection of seafood,...
...and we'll dine at some of Kyoto's famed kaiseki restaurants...
...like Hyotei, a first-class establishment...
...serving customers for more than 400 years.